i've had other customers be rude while
i've been in those bars really
apparently they've been like i think one
time i was with chris and we were asking
about um it was also a bar that made
food and we were ordering a bunch of
foods because we hadn't eaten all day
because we were like traveling and
filming yeah this one woman was like
don't you think you've ordered enough
food to like me and chris and we're like
never never enough food
shut up you're like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you why would you say that to
someone [ __ ] off
i think it's the she was annoyed because
she was talking with him i think she was
like flirting with her and we kept
obviously making him like actually like
cook and yeah do his job i guess and she
was like really annoyed
actually every time we ordered anything
she was like
and i'm like what's your problem
oh my god leave us alone we drank so
much she's trying to get the d dude i
know she [ __ ] off let us eat it's
because we ordered cannon there bro they
should have
because you're wearing cheese and stuff
you know chris was like more cameraman
because we were drinking so much we were
getting hungry more
more more
imagine trying to give them business
i thought i was so rude i was like what
the [ __ ] wrong with you i was in uh
kochi i think as well isn't this really
tiny like well
i bet for her that's like the only like
you know maybe yeah solace out of
whatever she's living through right yeah
i don't know
clearly she wasn't very happy you should
want to take it out on us i don't know
why i remember i mean it's caught you
there isn't a whole lot else yeah
i don't know it was a nice bar though i
remember there was like a it was like an
irish bar or something that's the theme
of it right right yeah it was really
good though because they did like they
had heineken on tap oh [ __ ] and i just
drank like and it was they had actual
pints of heineken oh yeah i was like
this is amazing
way too much because i was like so
excited to finally have a real sized
pine nuts yeah oh my god it's good
though
amazing sorry random tangent random
dance fine you guys haven't been to any
other like weirdly themed bars i mean i
know you have for a bunch for your
videos and stuff yeah like just outside
the
a lot of the cool bars i wouldn't want
to go film anyway i just want to just
kind of do it like there's that bar we
went to it's like this bar that's like i
don't i don't say it because i don't
want it to become like ramped yeah but
it's like they had like live music there
oh really it was like dude playing piano
cello i don't know violin and double
bass
oh that like
yeah kind of like a jazz bar there's
like and it's there's like the whole
wall is just like wine
yeah yeah i remember that one really
cool and they have like cigars and like
the atmosphere's very cheap chill it's
just nice
yeah it's super awesome these dudes are
amazing they're super chill just being
there yeah i really miss going to a bar
that has live music because like it's
like good as well yeah okay because
sometimes you good live music you're
like
i mean it's like not not too like
when the music's like not too in your
face yeah it wasn't too loud yeah yeah
sometimes you go to a bar and the music
the music like music is way too
aggressive that you can't focus on
anything else but the music yeah yeah
like this bar was just perfect the music
was just like you can have a
conversation or you can just like admire
this guy like
like tearing it up on like the trumpet
or saxophone right
whenever he was playing with the
with the piano yeah they were [ __ ]
insane really cool you can actually tip
them aside
they're like a tip jar
yeah i assume that's how they make most
of their money there but it's pretty
cool yeah very awesome but you get
charged for just like sitting down for
like the music charge oh yeah yeah
playing for like three hours yeah i mean
if the music's good
it's really [ __ ] good yeah so cool i
used to go to so many of those places in
uh in australia but um like they all
just got [ __ ] replaced by like just
standard like
poker machines and like what's the
what's the australian bar culture like
um i'd say pretty similar to the uk in
the sense that you go in you have you
know some food you know beers and
whatnot and then you watch the footy on
the tv kind of deal you know because
because like to me like
would you count a pub as a bar
yeah yeah
okay yeah it's not the same but it is in
definition it's it's i guess it's the
eog it fulfills the scene
it's only since i've moved out of
england that i've considered a pub a bar
right because before like i mean i mean
i get it it's a place that you go to
drink but to me like a pub always felt
different in the uk at least to a bar
you know a pub somewhere where
most of the time you go there to drink
but you know you can just have like a
nice sunday lunch you can have like a
nice breakfast there whatever as well a
bar is was always like somewhere you
would go before going to a club or
somewhere where you were
100 of the time like spend the night
getting [ __ ] faced yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah probably you can go to like in the
daytime as well i could never like
imagine having gone to a bar before 5 00
p.m you know right right or yeah i guess
in that sense then uh a pub is more so
similar to an izakaya in japan in that
instance whereas like a bar is just like
uh like as you know
most people normally go to at least in
the uk mo
see because for us it's like everyone
eats at the park i want to say 70 people
don't eat when they go to the pub really
yeah young i think the older you get the
more likely you are to eat at the pub
i think it's just a thing because you
wanna because the older you get the more
you wanna on weekends you wanna go hang
out with your mates yeah that's true
yeah yeah you wanna go read them for a
sunday
yeah yeah maybe i don't know i like pubs
pubs are interesting in the uk because
it's one place where you know it's also
a [ __ ] but also it's where like
there's also
a [ __ ] ton of historical significance to
some of these pubs yeah some pubs have
been around like 800 years in the uk
isn't it insane yeah that's insane
just some guy just pouring drinks has
been there for like 800 years yeah it's
like four times the length of australia
isn't that isn't that insane like there
are like pubs that are still open that
have been around for like like 500 plus
years that's crazy maybe not the same
name but like the location is this is
insane yeah and you go in and it's
depressing
because of course it's been around for
like 500 years right yeah
not much has changed i don't know pubs
are one of those places where it very
much reflects the local area the state
of it right like this is
the absolute state
you're going to the pub and you're like
all right we're we're going on if the
community is doing well the pub will be
nice
it's true everyone's happy the pub is
nice yeah that's true if it's an area
that has been like uh you know has been
like kind of forgotten by the the
shankings every week
you know it's kind of it's a it's a
reflection i don't know the pubs
it's like when you get to see the actual
i'd say the culture of the actual place
really is probably the most honest way
to find out about that
i i i i'd agree yeah and it's like if
you want to see what proper british
people are like you go to parks you go
to pubs right yeah like
you'll see you'll see that there's a
difference well i mean i remember before
where the image was different but now
you know if you it's it's not all just
like either
how can i wear this it's not we either
like primo premium proper people or just
whatever the [ __ ] we're getting clowned
on on the internet now i remember when
when i went to the uk and you took me to
that
gaming pub
on me we both took i mean yeah
no i'm pretty sure it was connor's idea
to bring you to that gaming con is like
i know a place
i think it was supposed to be chill but
i think that day specifically it was
because the overwatch world finals yeah
the overwatch world fight was happening
really [ __ ] because it's so busy and you
can get on but even even before the
actual finals started we got there a
little bit early before the finals
actually started so we could like at
least get a few drinks in and chill and
everything and i was like in my head you
know i was like oh okay a gaming pub in
the uk all right i wonder i wonder what
they have they just had a wii on the
windowsill
a single wii with with smash that's it
and five five pcs five pcs but the
pieces were all taking up because of the
overwatch uh yeah yeah yeah and uh i'd
never been unironically oid before until
that night
when i was like sitting outside because
the overwatch finals were happening
inside it was like way too loud and i
didn't really care so i sat outside yeah
just because there were a couple seats
outside yeah and yeah this this dude
clearly like about six pints in just
literally came up sat next to me and was
like
yeah that's all this is yeah that that
happens
wow you you exist i think i was playing
in an overwatch tournament that day i
think was that that day yeah i was it
was that was it yeah yeah yeah yeah you
are you took i think you i think you
signed up yeah yeah yeah
it was like a the winner got a free
drink yeah
it was like it was like a six-round
tournament yeah i got i think i've won
the first four matches yeah but then i'm
the fifth match i was like six beers
deep
yeah and so it was starting to get a lot
harder to win these 1v1s in overwatch
and then the guy i remember i got so
annoyed i was like the guy i'm going
against he was just drinking coffee and
i was like how is this fair i'm six
drinks deep and this guy he's just
drinking a [ __ ] starbucks yeah of
course i'm gonna lose i can barely like
[ __ ] sit in the chair correctly
and i didn't get my free drink i lost i
was very salty i think he was like a
[ __ ] rank as well i could have easily
been right yeah it could have been
sorry that's not right yeah i i do i do
notice that about it's especially like
themed bars in the uk because like the
uk the uk like themed bar game is
[ __ ] weak as [ __ ] i i don't know if
it's changed ever since i moved but like
you know like you you have in my day you
have a gaming bar in the uk right and
the gaming bar in the uk as joey has
just said it's just like a wii in a
corner and four pcs
yeah make sure they're not in business
before i
what was it called again i can't
remember what it was called melt oh
meltdown that was it meltdown i think
that was shut down it's closed i think
it's closed and it keeps reopening and
closing all right it's quite gritty
though yeah
all right i mean i still had a good time
it was better than nothing yeah
it was better than nothing but you
compare it to some of the gaming bars
and some of the theme bars you find some
of the gaming bars in tokyo are like
yeah in the uk they do have a new one
now i remember i went there
[Music]
but it was very expensive like to go on
the pc it was like
oh god um it was like paying normal
computer costs like computer cafe costs
in london yeah like five pounds for an
hour maybe right or maybe 30 minutes it
might have been five pounds for 30
minutes yeah like seven bucks and you
weren't allowed to take your drink up
obviously but that just kind of sucks
let's see but like that sounds like a
gaming bar where the gaming takes
priority over the bar right whereas
whereas meltdown was definitely like
92 percent bar eight percent gaming well
the thing i liked about meltdown was
that it was just i i don't know it's
just like it was just kind of like comfy
you know like
you can you could do you could do
anything in that bar you could like
order food from like the local pizza
place and eat to that barber oh yeah
yeah yeah like it's it was a cool place
to chill out but in terms of just like
having like a cool
themed bar where like you know a lot of
effort has gone into like the theming
and the vibe i mean i've been to bars in
america i've been to bars in like you
know in japan and you know you for
example you have like an anime themed
bar you have like a jojo themed bar in
japan and pete and like you can tell you
walk in and immediately it's just like
you're transported to a like a theme
park you know yeah thought has gone into
like the aesthetic the vibe the design
and then you go to like an anime bar in
the uk and it's a pub with a ducky maca
in the corner that's that's that's
basically like that's what i remember
like that's the absolute state of themed
bars in the uk
i'm saying all this [ __ ] about meltdown
i still had a good night it was a fun
time but it wasn't exactly it wasn't
exactly a gaming bug what's to say
that's that's the thing about uk boss
well you have fun there you have fun you
have fun you have fun it's just not what
you're expecting
well there's another one we didn't i
don't think we took you that's a board
game bar but also has video games right
yeah you told me about it but we decided
not to go to it for whatever reason it's
kind of far out the way yeah we went
there i went there the other when i went
back to the uk recently just for a drink
and it was rock band night right and uh
it was rough really because people are
singing
kind of karaoke but i don't know why
rock band makes people worse singers but
it was like i remember it was rough i
remember i was there i was like
oh you know i don't want to judge
singers because i'm [ __ ] myself but i
was like this is this is hard to drink
with
this is this is like wedding single
vibes yeah yeah even worse than that
yeah i i think just the problem with
having themed bars in the uk especially
um is that if you are going for like a
more delicate theme that requires more
you know that requires more thought and
more precision is that you have to make
everything drunk proof and not just
drunk but just like uk people drunk
proof and that's just like that's like a
much higher level chaos like because
this board game had a bouncer
so that should tell you how much like
this state of the uk the absolute state
like a board game bar right where you
would think that you know
us as nerds would go right we're like
chill right we need a [ __ ] bouncer
for it hold on right there watch your
top score scrabble all right
you've got a mortgage that probably
makes stop you right there you're broke
on monopoly have you finished a monopoly
game all right
so we got someone stabbed over a game
with uno the other night you know like
yeah it's kind of sad you're like yeah
like what's wrong with that so i can't
just [ __ ] not be [ __ ]
i've heard there's a lot of really fun
uh board game bars in tokyo i've never
been to any of them but i've i know of a
couple that i want to go to there's a
few in london actually there's one new
uh gaming bar in shinjuku actually this
one well there's one next to the aeroza
bar right uh era is a cafe in uh in
yeah there's a board game bar there
otherwise you'd need one that you'd kind
of if you're if you can't read japanese
you need to be somewhat familiar yeah
that's fine if you know a lot of them or
you have someone who can explain yeah
yeah most of these games i'm like i
don't want to read the manual i'll play
it with someone who knows they can just
explain this yeah yeah yeah it's much
better yeah like if if there is anyone
living in the uk that just does
legitimately go to a cool themed bar
please i would actually like to know if
if the uk bar game has been has improved
since i've moved out of the uk i'd like
that uh because like yeah compared to
compared to into what's available
internationally it is it is weak i will
say that it is weak but i mean i
understand it